[Musique]
avec un troupeau inscrits 250 vaches
allaitantes de race charolaise jean-luc
huguet n'a pas le temps de s'ennuyer
l'exploitation familiale qui se transmet
depuis trois générations a fait de la
sélection de la race sa priorité absolue
les murs des grange de la ferme sont là
pour témoigner de leur succès en
concours et cette passion dévorante ne
le quitte pas depuis plus de 30
je me sens très officiellement - en 87
mais bon je suis plus depuis tout gamin
de dans les années qui vous frappe c'est
quand vous avez déjà 7 8 ans avec votre
papa xavier concours et tout le bazar et
c'est là que ça vous fera quoi puis bon
le fait d'aimer ces bêtes là et puis
aimé le contact des gens quoi aimé
présenter quelque chose vous avez
maintenant mais il y avait beaucoup de
bêtes puis il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour ses intérêts sans quoi comme tout
compétiteur acharné jean-luc travail
pour produire le spécimen celui qui
pourra atteindre le concours général
agricole
historia une femelle de 6 ans et de 7
signé là c'est une bête que là tout le
temps tout le temps été en tête de
produire nous partout s'est présenté
quoi c'est une bête qui marque un
élevage quoi et d'un père qu'on a gardé
dix ans avec 250 et quelques bonnes nes
et voilà avec 70 75 autres vendus entre
pro de ce taureau et vendus dont 80 %
des élevages sélectionné à la tête du
petit veau ça sera comme la tête de la
vache tout sera bien entendu les corps
dans l'espace à la raf apprenez passe au
vert bien les lycées ouverts clic on
reste bien blanches bien filmé quoi vous
avez une demi heure trois quart d'heure
de douche parce qu'après folle et bien
l'essorer pour passer un produit pour
les pour le pour les pour l'époux faut
aller n'est pas habité on va pas suivre
jamais tu es dehors encore titulaire de
nombreuses récompenses dont un titre de
championne du monde dans la catégorie
génisse elle a raté de peu l'an dernier
la plus haute marche du podium parisien
cette fois avec son petit l'année
freinée en reculant elle va retenter sa
chance la sélection ça vous permet on
est connu de tout le monde ça vous
permet de découvrir tout un tas
d'élevage vous faites tous vos
livraisons de taureaux vous vous
découvrez les élevages nouveau vous
exposez ça vous apprend à avancer cette
passion qui se greffe à un travail déjà
très prenant jean-luc dit vouloir la
transmettre mais difficile de convaincre
les jeunes de passer des nuits dehors
pour les vêlages de travailler tout le
jour et de concourir les fans semaine
même son salon est consacrée à son amour
de ses bêtes
alors jean luc a déjà sélectionné celles
qui devrait remplacer historia dans les
prochaines années la passion ça ne
s'arrête jamais